hey what's up guys my name is channel
welcome back to my game engine series so
last time we added circle colliders make
sure you check out that video if you
haven't already it was extremely
exciting as always and so now we have
circle colliders we can render circles
we have box colliders we can render
rectangles and so what we can now do is
take all of that
and use it for the power of good and
actually visualize our colitis so this
is something that is extremely important
if we look at a scene such as this and i
hit play and all of that you know we can
see that we have a few physics kind of
uh you know colliders keep saying
colliders but what else am i going to do
so we can add a circle collider we can
add a rigid body 2d as well to this
circle and then suddenly this is
something that we can collide with now
that's great but when i start playing
with some of these parameters such as
like the offset or the radius of the
actual physics collider
i can't see any of it
playing with this radius does nothing
but yet if i make it like
i don't know three
then clearly this oh look there's a
circle in the way
right so those parameters are almost
useless because
uh i mean all i say almost because you
could
if you were really cool um and we we're
all cool here but if you were really
cool
what you could do is just scale up this
circle so it's currently at a scale of
one to like you know let's just say i
wanted the circle collider to be like
here and then what's that that's a scale
of 3.56
then what you could do is take i don't
even know why i'm doing this is the
worst episode but and then what you
could do is multiply or multiply 3.56 by
like 0.5 which would give you like 1.75
ish right maybe it was just 1.78 or
something and then now
look i've done it
i've made my collider go exactly where i
want and then still have this rendering
here without having collider
visualization i might just cut that part
of the episode honestly anyway the point
is it's nice to have colliders the other
thing you could do obviously is like i
don't know duplicate this circle make it
as big as you want
right and then just remove like the
circle renderer but obviously you'll
keep the collider and then you'll get
the same result a few different ways
here but the point is we obviously need
we obviously want the ability to
actually visualize these colliders so
how do we do that well we know that
we've added like pretty much all the
rendering functions we actually need
into our 2d renderer we have draw rect
and we have draw circle that's basically
all we need so now to actually visualize
these physics colliders we simply need
to make like a little button or
something in the ui that we can tick
like a checkbox that says hey please
show my visualizers and then
throughout throughout like our scene or
wherever we want to really do this we
can basically just go through all the
entities or at least go through all of
like the circle collider components all
of the box collider components and then
just like grab them and then render the
collider in the correct space so what
i'm actually going to do is i'm going to
do this in editor layer i don't really
want to add too much debug rendering
into the scene class itself because yes
this does render the scene but all of
these kind of overlays and we'll talk
probably a bit about this stuff in the
future when we get into maybe designing
some more debugging like tools i guess
but at the moment um you know obviously
our scene
if we render it it does like you know
for example it doesn't show gizmos right
it doesn't do all of this kind of know
what i tapped in there it doesn't really
do like all this kind of debug stuff
because what it's responsible for is
actually rendering this scene so i could
obviously easily be like hey by the way
you know when you draw this circle for
all the circle render components let's
make another view from the registry but
with circle collided components and then
just draw circles that's fine but that's
kind of like from a code organization
point of view it becomes complicated
doing it that way because we obviously
need to then make the scene aware of
do you want visualization do you not
want this kind of debug view like uh
you get all these settings and it just
becomes a huge mess not to mention that
the scene shouldn't really be doing all
this stuff so what i want to do in the
way that i'm kind of the way the design
works in my in my head at least is
basically we want to come in after the
scene is rendered and then be like okay
here is some extra debug fluff here's
some like graphics that are for debug
use or for editor use i'll say i want to
render that as like kind of like an
overlay right i don't want it to be part
of the scene i want it to be part of an
overlay and that way you know we can
easily toggle off the overlays all of
them right if we want to see a pure
image of our scene and we can kind of
manage that externally so that
when we actually go through the scene
for the use like we still do on update
editor and on update runtime there's
still two different things and that's
fine but when we actually like ship the
game we obviously don't need any of this
overlay stuff and it will all be hidden
in an editor layer which is in the
hazelnut project it's not even close to
being part of the runtime because this
hazelnut project right which you can
barely see there below the facecam that
does not ship at all only uh the run
time which we don't have we don't have a
run time yet we should uh we should get
on that
hazel like the big version of hazel
obviously has a run time and all that so
we will definitely cover that soon but
anyway point is we want to do it here so
i think we already do some kind of
overlay rendering obviously because we
uh well it's part of our i am gui
rendering really but we obviously render
like the gizmos right here they are so
we already have this kind of concept but
this is not an i'm going thing it's
going to be our thing meaning it's going
to be part of this thing so let's take a
look briefly at how our renderer even
works so we start off by binding a frame
buffer
sometimes i forget like how
far behind this kind of version of hazel
hazel 2d is compared to like the real
hazel but um we bind a frame buffer you
know we do all of this we clear it
whatever we set we cleared this
attachment to negative one because
that's our mouse picking code then we
render the scene however
we like and then what i want to do so
this is us actually picking the entity
which
it doesn't really matter where we
do this i guess um you know uh yeah it
doesn't really matter where we do this
stuff but i think i might do it i might
leave this as is but but before we um
unbind the frame buffer so what's this
function called on update you know we'll
do on overlay render or something like
that right
i'm just making this up as i go by the
way i don't really i think i did like i
did add visualization during a live
stream
but it's not something that i have open
and i'm actually doing it a different
way now surprise so
yeah um so let's just add on overlay
render
and this is obviously going to be
subject to like um whether or not these
this is actually enabled because
obviously we don't always want to render
overlays but basically what we need to
do and i'm sure that we had some
similar way of doing this don't we we
can can we ask the scene to give us like
a list of entities
we should be able to
uh no we actually can't okay
so what i want to do is in the scene i
want to write a function that will
basically
you know something like
um and we'll see because this has to
this is going to have to be like a
template and this is probably going to
end up being um so components a variatic
template here i always forget like where
this goes
but um basically what this is going to
do is it's going to return to us so we
can say get all entities with
and then it's going to get us it's
basically just this is just a wrapper
over the registry and then we can
obviously do view and then we can kind
of expand those component arcs or
whatever and then we can get back from
the registry of u of
uh all of these components and so this
is going to work basically the same way
that we you know like you can do view
get and then you can give a list of
components and it will give you that
view back this is exactly what's
happening here it's just that it's like
a template and we don't have to
interface with the registry directly but
this is just a function that we can call
and we will get back a view obviously
ant is something that is exposed
everywhere it's an anti-component system
it's header only it has to kind of be uh
it's made out of templates it has to be
kind of very um you know it's compiled
based on based on its usage so there's
no real way
at least no real way that i would want
to kind of black box that and keep it
kind of uh only like segregated into
like the hazel core library not into
like hazelnut runtime it should be it's
it's a it's a core system right so we do
want to kind of have access to it
everywhere um but back in editor layer
now in this what we can what we should
be able to do if i haven't made any
mistakes um is we should be able to do
like active scene get all entities with
and then we can list our components so
what do i want well i basically just
want like let's let's start with circles
so a circle collider 2d component
right and that should give me back my
view of those entities that i should
then be able to kind of iterate over and
this is already uh cannot deduce auto
type it's already going well but we'll
we'll fix it in a minute so i'll go
through um
how do i usually go through all of this
so for oh yeah automatically view
because they're going to be entities
okay let's see if we can fix this so
cannot introduce auto type and this is
upset oh well i haven't actually
returned this okay that's better um okay
so we'll go through all of these
entities and now what we're going to do
is basically uh render it now to render
it we need to render it in a particular
pass which i think we are still part of
and i think we might want to restructure
the rendering a little bit in the future
because at the moment if we take a look
at our on update function yes we do this
before we unbind we don't really have
the concept of render passes uh however
you know we um yeah so we should just be
able to composite all this on top and it
will still be read into the same frame
buffer so it will still be like depth
tested and all that stuff unless we
specifically disable that before we get
into like certain draw calls but what
i'll do is i'll do renderer 2d
uh begin scene
uh actually see this is when i'm so
begin scene what does that do exactly
does that that doesn't clear anything no
it just sets up sets the uniform data
and starts a batch sure
and then we need to give it some kind of
camera so let's give it the editor
camera
and then
end scene and so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to go through like all of
these uh
components and then i can do view dot
get circle collider 2d component and we
also need the transform component these
are the only two components that we need
for a particular entity
um
uh actually
i probably should try and use our api
for that maybe
or maybe not actually because this this
only can return one component at a time
so i can do view.get
should be able to and then we can we
should be able to do like transform
transform
and
circle collider 2d let's just say
like that right and then what what's
that gonna do ah i think it's because
this view doesn't so yeah so we do have
to place that in there as well okay cool
so we've got the transform component and
or maybe i'll just call this tc and then
the cc turn the circle out of 2d
um so what we can do now is obviously
access all those parameters and draw the
appropriate circle so let's just draw
the actual circle first so we'll do
renderer 2d draw circle and then we can
pass in a transform so that will just be
like the trend the transform from that
transform component
uh then we have like the color so for
the color we want something fairly
visible now in big hazel 2d colliders
are actually blue
because uh the green color is reserved
for 3d colliders because nvidia physics
is green and we just went with that so
that way we can kind of separate them
now for this engine though for hazel 2d
i'm not sure that we should make it blue
because
uh there are no 3d colliders because
this is a 2d engine so maybe we should
just make them green
and we can make them like
well i guess as visible as possible so
we can do zero one zero we could make
them a little bit brighter and in uh you
know some areas as well but this has to
be a vac4 but we can we'll we'll make it
green for now like this and we'll adjust
the color maybe later if we want to be
all artistic thickness um
maybe like 0.05 or something like that
actually one yeah because it's a filled
in circle but a fault fade we'll leave
as is an mtid doesn't matter okay so now
we're we're now drawing this at the
correct transform and everything's great
however obviously we're not taking into
account anything else we're not taking
into account uh the offset uh let's just
run this to see if it works but we're
not taking into account like the offset
the radius we're about to do that um
because otherwise this is just going to
be drawing this circle
what
[Laughter]
thanks uh let's just clean build this
because this is just falling apart okay
so after a clean build we're up and
running let's add in that circle
collider
and we don't see anything now one thing
that's worth noting is that obviously if
it's being rendered exactly in the same
spot then that won't render but however
if i offset this uh it's offsetting that
as well okay so let's do this let's bump
it up a little bit
now with the circle because i'm worried
that it's just getting clipped
with a circle the only way we can
apparently draw it is using a transform
that's okay so what we'll do is we'll uh
have our own kind of transform
which will be tc get transform
and then what i want to do is i want to
translate
uh it doesn't really matter where we do
this i think but what i want to do is
translate
that transform which maybe i'll
be a little cooler here and do like this
i'll translate that transform like
somewhere so let's do like
um
0 0
0.01 that might be too much but this way
we'll be able to push it forward a
little bit
and we'll also have to use like the
scale and all of that to actually take
into account the radius and the offset
so we'll have to translate it x and y as
well based on the offset which we're
about to do um and i should probably
save the scene we're still not seeing it
though so it's it might not be because
of that um
why are we not uh
this should be okay right
and begin scene and yeah i mean we
should be rendering this stuff right
i shouldn't uh okay so about five
minutes into my debugging i realized
that i'm doing a render a 2d begin scene
and renderer and scene not renderer 2d
and render and scene does absolutely
nothing so the point is whenever
flashing this so let's
let's yeah
great all right so now if i add my
circle collider hopefully we'll see it
there it is okay so we have a circle
collider now again we've pushed it ever
so slightly forward probably too much
because you can kind of see that it's
sitting on top of it now there are ways
obviously to just composite it on top at
exactly the same position
um
how will we do that well
i don't think we'll get into like the
specifics of that we could like disable
depth testing or something but that's
not going to be good because um then
it'll be on top of like everything and
we don't want it to be on top of
everything furthermore when we twist the
camera this way we actually want it to
be on top as well like we want to be on
top of of of the actual object that way
now the other problem is if we rotate
this that's not correct that's not what
that collider is actually like so
basically long story short i don't want
to use this existing transform even
though that's kind of the easy way to do
things we need to build up our own
transform so what do we know about this
well first of all it's a 2d collider a
2d collider means there is no depth
there's no z
none of that exists so if we take the
existing translation just the x y is
really what we need
so with that translation i then want to
offset it by that
circle collider offset
so that becomes
basically our position so translation
uh we can probably make this like a glm
vector
we'll take that translation we'll offset
it
and that will be our like translation i
guess
with that offset now the scale of this
or the size of this
we can also make up because and we can
make this a matrix because the scale is
going to be
whatever the trend whatever like the
scale actually is
um and actually why not make a matrix
out of it immediately but whatever the
scale is
um
so let's see so x y
and the radius kind of is like both the
x and y scale so scale
plus
would be plus the radius maybe it would
be times the radius
yeah it should be times the radius so
we'll do times glm
[Music]
i guess vec3 and then we'll do the
radius which is here as well
okay so we have the translation we have
the scale rotation none of that matters
especially for a
well it will matter for a like a box
collider forgot the word but for a
circle collider obviously you can't
rotate a circle collaterally anyway so
we just do that and that should be good
so translation scale and now out of this
we make our matrix so it's going to be
glm uh translate glm met four we'll have
a uh just a fresh map four here like
that and then this will be our
translation which we have to make a vec3
so we'll add a zero there and then we'll
multiply glm scale and that will be a
glm map for
storm going on outside damn um
i don't know if you guys can hear that
it's very loud
um okay so we've got scale and then this
will be the scale okay
and then this transform is what we'll
actually put into here so this should
now more or less be perfect but
the one thing maybe that we want to do
we'll make this effect 3
and
we can still probably you know do
this
but let's kind of adjust the offset so
what i'll do
is i'll make this offset a vec3
but
i'm going to again do that thing where i
push it like forward ever so slightly
and what we'll actually probably do is
push it this will be either positive or
negative depending on where the camera
is and we'll actually there's actually a
very easy trick we can do to kind of see
if the camera is behind or in front
because this is more or less in 2d space
so to speak okay so there's that
translation with that offset
and then uh let's go ahead and just add
that into there and we should be
probably good to go okay it's loading up
the scene keep forgetting to save but if
we take a look at that circle collat
okay so radius point five one
um i guess we probably did not want to
uh multiply that uh well that's because
it's radius not diameter so we do want
to multiply that but we'll double the
radius because obviously um when when we
actually draw the units we use our like
it's
the diameter matters because it's like a
one it's a one meter diameter um
uh circle okay so selecting that circle
collider now it's in the right place so
what we can do is uh we can expand it to
an arbitrary amount so like let's just
say we increase the radius to something
like one so that's looks correct to me
let's make it like one point
maybe like two no two is too much one
point
eight or something like that so that
should be right on the edge so if we hit
play
uh we got trent no okay so that didn't
quite work um and also we're still doing
this on the um
[Music]
we're still doing this on the update
which we shouldn't be doing let's
actually make this a rigid body that's
probably why it didn't work
and you can see yeah okay
it's really throwing me off that it's
rendering like that so maybe what we can
do is also it'd be nice to render it in
the runtime as well ultimately so this
begins scene this is gonna matter
whether or not we're in the run time or
not
so
let's go ahead and say uh that we'll add
a little switch statement i'll probably
design a slightly better way of doing
this because
yeah this is a bit annoying um but let's
just say uh maybe i'll just do if
the scene state equals
play then we probably need to ask the
scene
to get the primary camera entity
[Music]
and then from the camera and so this
gives us an entity right and then from
the camera
we can get component
uh camera components and we can ask for
its camera and we can begin seeing with
that
not much error checking but that should
be okay uh
and then ah the transform so the
transform is camera dot get component
transform components
dot get transform so that's pretty messy
but
gets the job done and then finally for
else we will begin
with the editor camera so that should be
good now
and uh
i think now we should probably see it
properly the thickness of the circle is
probably too much as well but let's take
a look and i will actually remember to
save the scene this time so circle
collider and rigid body 2d control s
uh let's play this that's fine you can
see it actually comes up obviously in
the correct spot for the runtime let's
now take that radius and make it like
2
1.9
and now you can see that's
that's perfect and then what we can also
do
is if we scale that back down to like
point five i can offset this wherever i
like this is way too fast though um
let's maybe move it
like uh
you know yeah it's negative point four
so point five is the interval which is
not uh very slow
um let's make it like one
maybe point five
right and then you can see there that
it's interacting correctly so that so
now obviously we are rendering this is
our actual object and we can still move
this around and scale it around and do
all of that stuff with it but it has its
own kind of offset that it can take into
account and that's actually what's used
or at least it should be that does not
look right anymore at all um
[Music]
still a static rigid body so now the
offset and the rate yeah what's going on
there
that's not correct at all
what happened there so the scale must
not be
taken into account correctly
but i multiplied that didn't i so the
radius times two would be one
one times two point one six
so i think that should probably
be correct transform component scale
times
the radius
yes
so that's just times one
and it did get bigger so maybe we're
actually sending in the wrong scale
when we start on runtime star but really
i thought we got that sorted out
oh we don't we don't get the scale at
all
oh okay well that's probably why so when
we actually hit start on this let's save
this crazy scene i don't know if control
s
how we still have not made a control s
button or like a save not a save as that
is just beyond me okay so if we close
this now let's actually make this work
so we should have the transform
somewhere else here's the transform so
what i want to do is basically
make this radius be
multiplied by and the thing is because
it's a radius it should be half
but radius already is half
so you can picture it this way radius if
the radius is set to 0.5 which is where
it is by default we have a size of one
so we can we should be able to simply i
don't know what i hit there simply
multiply this with the scale now the
problem is scale has three axes which
ones do we care about well circles are
more or less uniform so we're just going
to use the x-axis and call it a day
and i'll probably rewrite this the other
way around because primarily we will be
probably using the scale but now we
should hopefully get the correct
behavior from the scene that's
interesting because i thought i had done
that but i guess not so now if we hit
play um that's acting correctly which is
good okay so we've done circle colliders
everything looks pretty good to me let's
go ahead and uh jam it in as well for
um
for not circle colliders for
the other type of colliders i'm just i
have a way with words today uh for box
colliders so i'll make this a little
scope
just so it's easier to deal with
and then we're basically going to use uh
the same kind of situation here but with
box colliders yeah that's why i can't
even speak properly so i'm just saying
situation situations like my little
go-to word that i insert if i have no
idea what i'm talking about which is
pretty common okay so translation what
is it well we we have that same offset
we just don't have a radius i don't know
if we have a size offset i think we do
have a size offset which we can then
multiply i guess with the scale right so
we have a size
but this does not need to be multiplied
by two it simply becomes size and we can
multiply that by scale this is a vector
um so we'll have to if we do this
uh well z scale is just for rendering it
so i guess it doesn't really matter we
can just leave that at one it does not
matter what the
z scale is over here i think we set it
to be evenly proportionally scaled like
here but it ultimately doesn't matter
um
and then translation obviously will be
plus that offset and uh honestly i think
that's it we obviously want another
circle though we'll draw a rectangle at
that transform with the color and that's
pretty much it um now the do we have a
thick this is just you just use slime
rendering doesn't it so it doesn't
doesn't need any of that and then i'll
make this maybe slightly less thick
but that might be too thin we'll see
okay so that didn't work at all because
i forgot about rotation um so uh
rotation
because circles don't really have
rotation but we have rotation for our
that's the circles for our boxes so
let's add in that rotation tc dot
rotation the only one we care about is z
though so it's just going to be
rotation. and we don't have to offset it
or do anything to it and it's just going
to be a float let's just not probably
make this thing out of it let's just
multiply this with
a rotation matrix so rotate glm map for
one uh we could shove in the previous
matrix into here but i prefer writing it
this way to be honest and then this
becomes glm
um oh this is the axis actually so
vec3 will simply be zero zero and one
because we're doing the z axis and that
is the value of rotation now that should
be in radians i don't expect it to be in
degrees
but this has been a while so we'll see
now have we done this right now okay so
actually the angle goes first so we'll
just shove that in like that
and i think we're good we'll get rid of
rotation there we should
now be good to go with our hopefully
correctly rotated boxes
so here we go
um but the scale seems wrong so what is
so the scale is 6.5 all of that stuff
and the size of the size is yeah of
course it's half extents sorry i forgot
i for some reason i thought it wasn't
half extents so we need that times two
again so when we do the scale we'll take
that size we'll multiply it by two
and um we'll yeah z z scale doesn't
matter so we'll leave it as is and
finally we have correctly
uh drawn colitis they are a little on
the thin side so i think what i'll do is
um well the
specifically the circles what i'm
talking about
so let's make this
maybe 0.1.01 or something like that
we'll make them twice the size but
otherwise you know those other ones are
being drawn by lines we could simply
make
um
we could probably just yeah that looks
pretty good we could obviously modify
that line thickness we do have a way to
set that line thickness when we draw the
lines but other than that i think we're
pretty good to go and that works in the
runtime as well okay awesome so last
thing we need to do is obviously make
this like an option so that's going to
be pretty easy
we probably should manage this a little
bit better
we'll maybe have a ui planning episode
at one point but
sure physics
colitis equals false
so if that is true we do this whole
thing um
now because we will be rendering other
stuff i'll actually just
not kind of exclude this we'll always do
this even though we technically don't
need to because i think we'll be drawing
other stuff
um not just colliders so we might want
to draw icons and all this other stuff
so i'm not gonna hide i'm not gonna stop
like this from happening but obviously
if this is all you are truly doing you
probably wanna just basically do
something like if not show physics
colliders return and then obviously none
of this code will run and you'll be good
but i'll do it this way for now okay so
this is our
oops these are our box colliders
these are our
circle
colliders
okay looks good to me and then finally
let's make that ui option i think we
have like a settings panel or something
no i totally thought we did uh where
where are all of our panels so we have a
stats panel
that's it
all right well that's uh fun um let's
make a this i guess we can make a
settings panel so i'm going to begin
where's the end here
we probably should design some kind of
panel manager as well this series really
is endless uh settings maybe this will
be the viewport settings i don't know
but for now we'll just add a little
check box called
show
show physics colliders and then we will
add in that show if it's colliders
option hit f5 and we should be
we should be brilliant we should be good
to go so the settings panel i'm just
going to dock it up here or maybe i'll
dock it down here
um and then obviously at the moment
we're not showing anything i take that
on and we see everything
uh yeah what more could you want you
guys see that yeah you can um that's
physics colliders now there is one
little thing left as i mentioned and
that is but what about if we look at it
from this side
well the lines seem fine but the circle
is not on top of this anymore and if i
reset this from its offset to be in the
right place we don't see it at all we
only see it from this side so this is
going to be a little exercise for you
guys how would you make it so this
circle collider is visible from this
side as well if you want to contribute
and like solve this issue then you can
go to
the github page which i definitely
wasn't prepared to explain this but um
if you go to the repository you can open
an issue being like you know circle
colliders rendering always on top of
geometry or something like that and then
i will discuss the pull requests that
come in you can make an issue out of it
if it's just a bit of code and you want
to make a discussion maybe i should make
an issue and then i'll let you guys do
it but maybe in the future i'll make
issues so that we can all discuss this
and propose solutions in one place
but uh
yeah if you have a way to solve this um
open an issue and we will or a pull
request and we will talk about it next
episode uh otherwise if no one opens an
issue then i'll show you my solution for
this uh which i think is actually
already in the dev branch of um
of this hazel 2d repository but anyway
thank you guys for watching i hope you
enjoyed this video if you did please
don't forget to hit the like button
patreon.com the channel is the best way
to help support this project these
videos this video series my whole
channel my whole career everything is
going on so huge thank you to all the
supporters that make all of this
possible
next time we will continue on doing
whatever it is we need to do with this
never ending engine and i'll see you
guys then goodbye
[Music]
you